one of the most exciting recent
developments in people earning has to
the rise of end to end deep learning so
what is entering deep learning briefly
there's been some data processing
systems or learning systems that require
multiple stages of processing and what
end-to-end deep learning does is it can
take all those multiple stages and
replace it usually with just a single
neural network let's look at some
examples tic speech recognition as an
example where you go is to take an input
X such an audio clip and map it to an
output Y which is a transcript of that
audio clip
so traditionally speech recognition
require many stages of processing first
you will extract some features some hand
design features of the audio
conservative heard of M FCC that's an
algorithm for extracting the certain set
of ten design features for video and
then having extracted some low-level
features you might apply a machine
learning algorithm to find the phonemes
in the audio clip so phonemes are the
basic units of sound so for example the
word cats has made other three sounds
that cut up and tuck so these strike
those and then you string together
phonemes to form individual words and
then you string them together to form
the transcription of the audio clip so
in contrast to this pipeline both of all
the stages what end-to-end deep learning
does is you can create a huge new
network to just input the audio clip and
have it directly output the transcript
one interesting sociological effect in
AI is that as and deep learning started
to work better there were some
researchers that had for example spent
many years of the career designing
individual steps of the pipeline so
there were some researchers in different
disciplines not just a speech
recognition maybe in computer vision and
other areas as well their sense of all
the time you know written multiple
papers maybe even build a large time and
career engineering features or entering
other pieces of the pipeline and when
end-to-end deep learning just took a
large training set and learn the
function mapping from X&Y directly
really bypassing a lot of these on
intermediate steps it was a challenging
for some
to come round to accenting this
alternative way of building a our
systems is because it really also leads
it in some cases many years of research
in some of the intermediate components
it turns out that one of the challenges
that incentive learning is that you
might need a lot of data before works
well so for example if you're training
on three thousand dollars of data to
build a stage recognition system then
the traditional pipeline there's full
traditional pipeline works really well
it's only when you have a very large
data set you know want to say ten
thousand dollars of data and anything
going up to maybe a hundred thousand
dollars of data that deep end-to-end
approach then suddenly starts to work
really well so when you have a smaller
data set the more traditional pipeline
approach actually works just a small
often works even better and you need a
large dataset 240 end-to-end approach
really shines and if you have a medium
amount of data and they're all so
intermediate approaches where maybe
input audio and bypass the features and
just learn I'll put the phonemes of the
neural network and then have some other
stages as well so there's be a step
toward end-to-end learning but not
ultimately they're just so this is a
picture of a face recognition turn spell
built by a researcher into Lin and I do
where this is a camera and it looks at
the person approaching the gate and if
it recognizes a person then you know the
turnstile automatically lets them do so
rather than needing to swipe an RFID
package to enter this facility it
increasingly many offices in China and
hopefully one more in other countries as
well you can just approach the turnstile
and if it recognizes your face it just
lets you through without needing you to
carry an ID badge so how do you build a
system like this well one thing you
could do is just look at the image that
the camera is capturing all right so I
guess is my bad drawing but maybe this
is a camera image and you know you have
someone very approaching the turnstile
so this might be the image
X billion zillion camera is capturing
and one thing you could do is try to
learn a function mapping directly from
the image X to the identity of the
person Y but turns out this is not the
best approach and one of the problems is
that you know the person approaching the
turnstile can approach them lots of
different directions so there could be
it's a green position to get of a blue
position you're and sometimes they're
closer to the camera so they appear
bigger and DMH and sometimes they're
already closer to the camera so their
face appears much bigger so what is
actually done to build these turnstiles
is not to just take the raw images and
feed it on your net to try to figure out
the person's identity instead the best
approach today seems to be a multi-step
approach where first you run one piece
of software to detect the person's face
so this first the detector to figure out
where is the person's face having
detected the person's face you then zoom
in to that part of the image and crop
that image so that the person's face is
centered then it is this picture so I
guess I drew here in red this is then
fed to a neural network to then try to
learn or estimate the person's identity
and what researchers have found is that
instead of trying to learn everything on
one step by breaking this problem down
into two simple steps first is figure
out where is the face and second is look
at the face and figure out who this
actually is the second approach allows
the learning algorithm or really two
learning algorithms to solve to much
simpler tasks and results in overall
better performance by the way if you
want to know how the second step
actually works are simplified to
discussion by the way if you want to
know how step two here actually works
i've actually simplified the description
a bit the way the second step is
actually trained as you train a neural
network that takes us input two images
and what in your network does is it
takes us input two images and it tells
you if these
two are the same person or not so if you
then have say 10,000 employees IDs on
file you can then take this image and
grid and quickly compare it against
maybe all 10,000 employee IDs on file to
try to figure out if this picture and
written is indeed one of your 10,000
employees that you should allow into
this facility know that it should allow
into your office building if this is a
turnstile that you know is giving
employees access to a workplace so why
is it that the two-step approach works
better
they're actually two reasons for that
one is that each of the two problems
you're solving is actually much simpler
the second is that you have a lot of
data for each of the two sub toss in
particular there is a lot of data you
can obtain for face detection for toss
one over here where the toss is to look
at an image and figure out you know
where is the person's face in the image
so there is a lot of data but there is a
lot of label data X comma Y where X is a
picture and Y shows the position of the
person space so you could build a neural
network to do task one quite well and
then separately there's a lot of data
for task two as well today leading
companies have let's say hundreds of
millions of pictures of people's faces
so given a closely cropped image like
this red image or this one down here
today leading face recognition teams
have you know at least hundreds of
millions of images that they could use
to look at two images and try to figure
out the identity or we figure out the
same person on so there's also a lot of
data for task two but in contrast if you
were to try to learn everything at the
same time there is much less data of the
form X comma Y where X is an image like
this taken from the turnstile and Y is
the identity of a person so because you
don't have enough data to solve this
end-to-end learning problem but you do
have an update ER to solve subproblems
one and two in practice breaking this
down to two sub problems results in
better performance than a pure
end-to-end deep learning approach
although if you hide an update for the
end-to-end approach maybe the end-to-end
approach would work better but that's
not actually what works best in practice
today let's look at a few more examples
take machine translation traditionally
machine translation systems also add a
long complicated pipeline where you
first take say English text and then do
text analysis basically extract a bunch
of features of the text and so on and
off there are many many steps you then
output say a translation of the English
text into French because for machine
translation you do have a lot of pairs
of English comment French sentences end
to end deep learning works quite well
for machine translation and that's
because today it is possible to get a
large data set of XY pairs where that's
the English sentence and that's the
corresponding French translation so in
this example a deep learning works well
one last example let's say that you want
to look at an x-ray picture of a hand of
a child and estimate the age of a child
you know when I first heard about this
problem I thought this is very cool
crime scene investigation task where you
find maybe tragically a skeleton of a
child and you want to figure out how old
the child was it turns out that um
typical application of this problem
estimating a child from an x-ray is less
dramatic than just crime scene
investigation or filtering it turns out
that pediatricians use this to estimate
whether or not a child is growing or
developing normally but a non end-to-end
approach to this would be revoking an
image and then you segment out or
recognize the bones so know just try to
figure out where is that bone segment
where at that bone segment where at that
bone segment and so on and then knowing
the length of the different bones you
can sort of go to a lookup table showing
the average bone lengths in a child's
hand and then use that to estimate a
child's age and so this approach
actually works pretty well in contrast
if you were to go straight from the
image
to their child's age then you would need
a lot of data to do that directly and as
far as I know this approach does not
work as well today just because there
isn't enough data to train this toss
into end fashion whereas in contrast you
can imagine that by breaking down this
problem into two steps step one is a
relatively simple problem maybe you
don't need that much data read only
damning x-ray images to segment out the
bones and toss to well you know by
collecting statistics of a number of
children's hands you can also get decent
lessons of that without too much data
so there's multi-step approach it seems
we are promising maybe more promising
than the end-to-end approach at least
until you can get more data for the
end-to-end learning approach so an enter
ng of learning works it can work really
well and it can really simplify the
system and not require you to build so
many hand design individual components
there's also not panacea it doesn't
always work in the next video I want to
share you a most systematic description
of when you should and maybe when you
shouldn't use end to end deep learning
and how to piece together these complex
machine learning systems